not one but two factions of Orthodox
Jews clashed in Crown Heights yesterday
among themselves and with the NYPD over
what to do about the secret Jewish
tunnel in
Brooklyn I'm Michael nlls this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show in a moment
we'll get to the pro Palestine
protesters vandalizing us uh military
cemeteries and blocking highways first
though we have to get to the Jewish
tunnel in Brooklyn day is it it's
January 9th it was pretty quick we're
not and the story broke on the e8th we
got eight days into
2024 before we got to the craziest
headline I've read in weeks at least I
guess I don't know there are a lot of
crazy headlines these days uh yes there
is a secret Jewish tunnel in Crown
Heights Brooklyn and we at the Michael
nll show have obtained exclusive footage
actually of of the extent of these
tunnel networks uh roll the
tape
okay kicks a little bit
second what's underneath that
sidewalk oh wait a second
it's hundreds of hodnik dancing to EDM
music that's amazing I don't know I I
think we need to verify that footage I'm
not sure that that is okay we've got
other footage though uh the footage came
out last night and this is in the
worldwide headquarters of habad now for
those of you who did not grow up in New
York as I did you probably don't know
what habad is and you probably don't
know very much about all the different
factions of Jews having grown up uh in
New York where most of my friends were
Jews and like most people just around me
were Jews I am fairly well acquainted
with the distinctions between the habad
laich Jews which that these are the ones
with the Shool in the tunnel then
there's another group that kind of look
like them which is the hered Jews
sometimes called the ultra Orthodox Jews
then there are the reformed Jews they're
the ones who aren't all that religious
but you know they eat a lot of bagels or
something then there are the
conservative Jews who take the religion
a little bit more seriously then there
just all these different distinctions
and the one we're talking about here is
habad this whole
story reminds me of of one fact which
is I really like the
hodnik and and the story is not just a
local story about New York the story is
not just sensational and silly because
it's really weird uh the story actually
has political import for all of us
because I think everybody can learn a
political lesson from the hodnik the
reason I like the hodnik is not just
because they're personally uh very
Charming people it's
because they have been able to
maintain tradition and a coherence
within their community and big families
and politic iCal power that they can
wield in their communities while also
thriving in modernity they've they've
done something that that a lot of people
have struggled to do and it's a lesson
that any traditional sort of person uh
might be able to copy apparently what
was going on in this tunnel story is
there's a debate over who has the rights
to operate the habad headquarters and
there are two groups there's the habad
international call it you know the the
global organization and then there's
this group of particularly zealous I
suppose it's being reported as Messianic
kind of hodnik students who had come in
and were insisting on digging this thing
so something that would deflate a lot of
the conspiracy theories that I've
seen floating around I know because you
know the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth is six months when
it's Dr fouchy and all these guys saying
it people are open to these sorts of
things but I think something that
deflates some of the theories about the
hodnik in Brooklyn is it was one group
of the hodnik that ordered the tunnel to
be filled in the first place it's not as
though there was just this unified
movement to dig a secret tunnel it was
this group of uh students who were who
were digging it contrary to the wishes
of the people who had the legal right to
operate the school and so then they call
in the cops and they try to fill in this
thing uh and and this inter intra habad
battle was will go on and on and on but
even with that one it shows you that all
political communities have these debates
and these factions and these rival
parties but broadly
speaking these guys dress in a
respectable way they take their religion
seriously they have big families they
even when there is factionalism they
operate in a way that is politically
cohesive and effective that's something
we should
all seek to emulate I think even if we
don't dig the tunnels which is generally
probably a bad idea a and might threaten
the buildings around them all in all a
story that I find very very delightful
now speaking of Faith there's a new
morning consult poll out that says that
uh faith in democracy remains very
strong uh I think this poll is total BS
so you you look at it and you can see
all the little tabs and and not only
does morning console believe that faith
and Democracy in America remains strong
it's faith and democracy everywhere that
they take the polls all of the countries
that they survey
okay all well and good except that as
the Harvard law professor Adrian vermule
points
out democracy means two things in
America two things that are contrary to
one another when the libs talk about
democracy in the same breath they will
talk about how important it is to kick
Donald Trump off the ballot and stop
people from being allowed to vote for
him we conservatives listen to that we
say what are you you're saying it's
democratic to stop the people from
voting for their favorite candidate yeah
and the Liberals really believe that
that is democratic they believe that
democracy and liberalism are synonymous
even though
liberalism is a minority ideology it's
uh can be deeply deeply unpopular and
then it's imposed from above and it uh
is a totalitarian ideology I guess you
would say it infiltrates every aspect of
life that's how it's managed to corrode
not just federalism not just
constitutional protections but it's
corroded even the family it it's
corroded even local Rule and and it just
it's like an acid that you pour on
society until everything is just
uh divided up and alienated into the
atomic individual that's no good that's
not how I refer to democracy when I say
I support democracy what I mean is I
support the people voting for who whom
they want to vote for
that's a very different meaning of
democracy so I just don't think this
this PLL means anything at all it be
it's similar to saying Hey do you
support Freedom you could ask me a
rather conservative person do you
support freedom I say of course I
support Freedom you could ask some crazy
purple hair doing a bunch of drugs who's
in you know a lesbian thruple with with
three dudes in a billy goat and I would
say do you support freedom and she would
say of course I support freedom but we
would think that the other one does not
support freedom because we have
different understandings of Freedom the
lib would believe that freedom is the
ability to do whatever you want
particularly following your base
passions and I would believe the
opposite I would say the true freedom is
disciplining your base passions and
following your rational will and
bringing that into Accord with the
Divine will that that true freedom is
the right to do what we ought not the
ability to do what we wish at our lowest
levels those are totally in Conflict but
a morning consult survey that said do
you all support Freedom say 100% of
people support Freedom 100% of people
support democracy and and the centrists
are going to sit back here and say okay
good the guard rails hold no big deal
the guard rails are not holding right
now this is Happy Talk this is papering
over a fundamental difference and it
gets down to a number one National
bestselling book that I recommend that
everyone read called speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
thank you
because all this happy talk is papering
over a a battle over language whose
definition of democracy is going to
Prevail for all of human history
democracy was the political order that
the people want the Liberals have
totally perverted that meeting they will
go on TV with a straight face they will
say we've got
to legally prohibit Donald Trump from
appearing on a ballot in order to save
democracy we've got to overturn the
Trump Administration after he wins in
2016 to save democracy oh no the Arians
are electing Victor orbon he's a threat
to democracy Georgia Malone is a threat
to democracy the brexit's a threat to
democracy all these things that the
people keep voting for it's a threat to
democracy who's going to who's going to
win that battle over the word it's a
very very powerful word still has so
much currency but but for all intents
and purposes it no longer means what
what it traditionally has meant what it
actually means now when we want to
protect ourselves from these powerful
Elites who want to destroy us we got to
check out expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com have you noticed that big
tech companies masquerade as privacy
companies they tell you fix your privacy
settings turn off app tracking and
you're protected big Tech watches where
you go online and then collects and
sells your data to protect myself
against big Tech's prying eyes I prefer
expressvpn I trust expressvpn and it's
easy enough that I can actually use it
when you use expressvpn on your computer
or your phone you are hiding your unique
IP address at the sites can't find out
your real location or track what you do
online expressvpn also encrypts and
reroutes 100% of your online activity so
your ISP Wi-Fi admin and hackers cannot
see best part is you do it with one
button one expressvpn subscription
covers up to five devices at the same
time you can protect your whole family
too it's rated number one by me and CET
and wied tech radar and a lot of others
today is the day get the VPN that I
trust to protect my online privacy when
Big Bad Tech is at the door
expressvpn.com
KW you get three extra months for free
on a one-year package
expressvpn.com
expressvpn.com to learn more speaking of
democracy the Supreme Court will hear
the case about Trump being kicked off
the ballot in Colorado the court agreed
to review the unprecedented decision and
that's a very good thing but we can't
just rest easy on that we can't just say
well the guard rail are certain to hold
there's no way wouldn't it be so crazy
if the Supreme Court didn't let the most
popular presidential candidate in the
country on the ballot I don't know
strange things have been happening in
recent years wouldn't it be so crazy to
shut down the entire world over a a
cough wouldn't it be so crazy to shut
down churches and synagogues in New York
actually in that neighborhood that we
were just talking about over a cough and
suspend fundamental constitutional
rights wouldn't that be just nuts
wouldn't it be crazy to change all the
election rules in the weeks before a
presidential election in a way that
totally advantages the opposition
supposedly opposition political party
the Democrats wouldn't that be so crazy
and then it just happens so I'm I am not
convinced that the Supreme Court is
going to do the right thing here because
the Supreme Court pays attention to the
polls the Supreme Court reads the news
the Supreme Court doesn't want the
Democrats sending any more assassins to
go kill them like the Democrats did in
the case of Brett Kavanaugh like the
Democrats did in the case of all the the
conservative justices Sam Alo had to go
into
hiding yeah I think that the the
political
pressure might might be too much for
them and so what the conservatives have
to do the rest of us who are not on the
Supreme Court we have got to bring
political pressure to bear on the other
side not the Democrat kind of political
pressure which is where you go send
assassins after your enemies whether the
Assassins are a BLM mob or the Assassins
or some Looney Tune from California
trying to kill a Supreme Court Justice
what what the political pressure we need
to bring to bear is has to be just it
has to be moral but it's got to be
effective so one thing we could do I
suggested it on the show the other day
it was not an original idea I thought it
was a brilliant idea but I can't take
credit for it I heard it from lowercase
G lowercase k over here Mr Jeremy boring
and he said you know what the
conservatives have to do we need a
conservative governor and specifically a
conservative Secretary of State to kick
Biden off the
ballot I'm sure there's some reason to
kick Biden off the ballot we're in
totally unchartered territory here we
are in an unprecedented political
situation but there's probably some
reason and it's probably a better reason
than the nonsense they're cooking up to
kick Trump off the ballot and let's say
you don't even want to figure out why to
kick Biden off the
ballot you could probably kick KL off
the ballot pretty easily right using the
argument of the left the left is saying
that Donald Trump engaged in an
Insurrection and they're a little fuzzy
on the evidence for how he engaged in an
Insurrection because he didn't you know
he didn't go take over the capital he
told people to be very peaceful he told
people to go home when they were
demonstrating at the capital the whole
capital Riot to begin with wasn't even
in the top dozen insurrections that have
ever taken place at the capital the vast
majority of which were left-wing in
nature and then when the guys did get
into the capital A lot of them were
given private tours by the Capitol Hill
Police it was just total BS they didn't
have weapons the only person who was
killed in the political violence that
day was a prot trump person who was shot
by a trigger happy
cop so what's the argument for kicking
Kamal off the ballot the argument for
kicking KL off the ballot is that she
raised money to bail out violent
criminals during the George Floyd
riots she wasn't bailing out the
peaceful protesters she was bailing out
the violent criminals who got arrested
for breaking the law so kick her off the
ballot easy enough right and then then
you've broken up the Democrat ticket and
it's going to go up to the Supreme Court
and then the Supreme Court has the
political cover to say all right we're
not kicking anybody off the ballot the
people will have their say which is all
we want in the first place I don't
really care about kicking KLA Harris off
the ballot frankly I'd put her at the
top of the ticket because she's one of
the worst politicians I've ever seen but
we've got to at
least we've got to at least engage in
the political realities according to
Justice and according to to morals but
we got to do it in in a battle your
opponent has a say and that's what we're
looking at here well I'm glad to report
some people have heed the call the
Missouri Secretary of State Jay Ashcroft
is now threatening to remove Biden from
the ballot uh if the Supreme Court does
not reverse Colorado's decision so this
is according to a report from NBC and I
really really applaud Secretary of State
Ashcraft here I think this is great news
my only quibble with it is I think
you've got to be more aggressive about
it I I don't think it is that I don't
think it is sufficient to say okay if
the Supreme Court declines to overturn
the case then we're going to kick Biden
off the ballot in fact in a way that
that might make the situation more tense
that might raise the heat what I'm
trying to do is lower the heat here okay
I think you've got to bring that
political pressure to bear before the
case is decided so that the Supreme
Court can say okay look we don't really
want to get into this game where one the
party candidates are only appearing on
the ballots in their respective states
where their parties have a majority we
don't want to get into that situation
that's Civil War territory so you know
what look hey sorry Democrats but do you
really want that look the Republicans
are already kicking Biden off the ballot
you really want that just so that you
can kick Trump off in Colorado which
he's not going to win anyway I don't
think so I don't think okay we're just
going to back off this thing no one gets
kicked off the ballots that's that's
what I would do I'm not a secretary of
state in Missouri or anywhere else
Governor Dan santis has floated this
idea he said I'm having my
Administration look into whether or not
we ought to kick Joe Biden off the
ballot he said this just a couple of
days ago so it's bubbling up I'm glad to
see that Republican politicians are
taking this seriously but I think this
would be a case where a half measure is
worse than no measure at all I think a
half measure has the potential to make
this a much more volatile situation if
the if we just wait if we make little
mild Meek threats then the Supreme Court
says all right there's not enough
pressure coming from the right we'll
just give the Democrats what they want
in Colorado and maybe in Maine where
Trump was also kicked off the ballot
then all of a sudden the the Republicans
are going to want retribution and you
might really end up in a situation where
the red states have the Republican on
the ballot the states have the Democrat
on the ballot and we're just going to
Duke it out and no one's going to accept
the results of the election I think you
sometimes you got to you got to have
have peace through strength as Ronald
Reagan would say you've got to you've
got to bring that pressure early make
clear that the threat is
legitimate and then we can move on and
have a semi-normal election speaking of
these early primaries the hill which is
a center leftish news Outlet is is
reporting in an oped so this is an
opinion piece that DeSantis will drop
out after
Iowa uh this oped from the hill says
I've heard from two people very familiar
with the disantis campaign a major donor
and a highlevel political operative that
if the Florida governor loses the Iowa
caucuses to former president Trump as
expected on the night of January 15th he
will either drop out of the race that
night or make his announcement the next
morning and then there's an editor's
note here on the SED says the disantis
campaign vigorously denies this
assertion this oped has been updated to
include the following statement from the
campaign Rond STIs is in this for the
Long Haul
okay I think both statements are correct
actually I think it is likely that if
DeSantis loses Iowa that he will drop
out but I also believe that DeSantis
campaign is telling the truth which is
that the campaign's going to stay in it
as long as it can the the reason for
this is I spoke to a friend of mine who
is very familiar with presidential
campaigns and he told me we were going
back through some of the older
presidential campaigns 2012 when this
candidate dropped out and this candidate
I said well I think he dropped out for
this reason and he dropped out for that
reason and my friend said
Michael presidential campaigns end for
one reason and one reason only because
they run out of money that's why they
end that's why people SS because they
can't go on any further now Dan santis
had raised a ton of money the STIs
campaign also burned a ton of money but
if thec campaign looks at Iowa sees that
they're going to lose and who knows
maybe they'll pull a huge upset and then
looks at New Hampshire sees for sure
they're going to lose and then looks at
this state and this state and this state
the only way they could even possibly
make a claim to be able to compete in
some of these states is to spend oodles
and oodles of cash they're not going to
be able to raise any more money when the
donors smell blood in the water and the
campaign will end them they'll be in it
for the long haul but circumstances H
have a way way of forcing the hand of
candidates and it can happen really
quickly we've just gone through what 16
18 months already of of candidates
running or signaling that they're going
to run or starting to raise money and
it's going on for a really long time and
nothing has really happened the minute
that voting starts the minute you see
the Iowa caucuses the minute you see
some of those early primary States
things are going to
winow
pretty pretty quickly I think now
there's a new number two candidate in
the race at least According to some
polls
but that candidate is facing some
problems now as well we'll get to those
in just one second first though I got to
talk to you about what I had for dinner
last night which would be good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com use
code NES you know what I had for dinner
last night I come home and Alisa said I
just made a quick little sauce I said
okay so it's just pasta well I forget
what kind of pasta and a nice little
sauce and but it was easy you know you
make it in 10 minutes so she makes this
up whatever I said oh this is really
good sauce what kind of sauce is that
just a little meat sauce just quick meat
sauce I said I don't know what you know
meat sauce is easy it's just the canned
tomatoes and the this and that so then
it occurred to me the only thing that
that would have determined how tasty the
sauce was was the meat so I said well
where'd you get this is like the best
meat sauce I've had in a long time he
goes huh oh I just got the the good
ranchers hamburger and I kind of just
and it was the good ranchers meat of
course it was good ranchers has the
absolute best meat out there their
chicken is unbelievable their beef is
unbelievable they're all their stuff
they've got everything and it's the best
in the business and the prices are the
lowest in the business somehow and it
sells itself I don't know how they do it
go to goodranchers.com use code NES kwes
to enjoy free chicken in 2024 plus an
additional 20 bucks off your first order
change the way you buy meat by switching
to good ranchers subscribe today use
code nolles kwes to claim over 200 bucks
in free chicken and New Year savings
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
Nikki Hal's campaign is feeling pretty
good because a lot of people wrote them
off in the early days of the campaign
and Des santis looked as though he were
the only Republican who could possibly
unseat Donald Trump and
then some of us suggested early on that
Nikki Haley is a very talented
politician who would be able to last
pretty long in the race and that DES
santis in part because he's so good in
part for the reasons that make him so
likable and admirable he was going to
have a very hard time in the race and
was going to be a man without a home and
he'd go away and you know some of us
appear to have been proven correct in
that
prediction Nikki Haley is is facing the
problem that was always going to crop up
because it's also her strength Nikki's
strength is she has a ton of Centrist
establishment
cred and she has played very well with
the right of her party sometimes too she
has the backing of the coke Network she
was a relatively moderate governor in
South
Carolina also she worked for Donald
Trump she was the UN Ambassador she
brought it to the bad guys every day and
Trump FedEd her as she as she
left the administration and said oh
Nikki you're welcome back whenever
you're so great we love you and and
that's that's a really hard tight RPP to
walk and she's managed to do it pretty
well but it does lead to certain
contradictions so there was a town hall
in Iowa now we're days away from the
Iowa caucuses Nikki Haley was asked what
her opinion is on Social Security reform
here is an unfortunate answer so
Governor uh Governor DeSantis is hitting
you for claiming the retirement age is
quote way way too low he said quote I
don't know why she's saying that so are
you saying that where do you I never
once said that well wait wait wait wait
in Bloomberg interview you said um
anyone who says they'll leave America
bankrupt Social Security will go
bankrupt Medicare will so we don't touch
anyone's retirement but go to people
like my kids in their 20s and tell them
the rules haven't changed change the
retirement age to reflect life
expectancy guess okay so it's it's a
little bit of a tricky one and Brett
Bear here he's a very good journalist so
he tests to see if Nikki is going to
give a nuanced answer on desantis's
accusation Nikki Haley wants to raise
the retirement age for Social Security
she's going to gut entitlements and
Nikki says I absolutely have never said
that and then he says well hold on did
CU I have this statement and I'm sure we
don't have the rest of the clip I'm sure
Nikki had a masterful response to that
and she probably would have said I I'm
almost certain I'm right about this I
haven't even seen the rest of her answer
she would say well no what I'm saying is
I certainly will not raise the
retirement age for people who are at
retirement or even anywhere close to
retirement but the Social Security fund
is going to go bankrupt and so if we
want our children whove been paying into
it to have any Social Security at all we
need to raise the retirement age and
reform entitlements okay fair enough
that was the answer that we
heard 2010 2011 2012 that was a big
motivator of at least
the uh more mainstream establishment
wing of the Tea Party Movement the
reason that the the coke Network backed
the Tea Party Movement was because they
were real fiscal Hawks and they said we
got to shrink the budget we got a we got
a reform entitlements there was another
side of the Tea Party Movement which was
a little bit more populist and was a
little bit more Grassroots which was
just a a a an anger that the government
under Barack Obama was becoming
tyrannical that it was spinning out of
control that it was being wielded
against political enemies that our our
basic freedoms and traditions were being
upended that our border was being blown
wide open that that we weren't being
respected that that our president now
was sneering was looking down his nose
on those bitter clinging Bible thumping
Rubes and idiots who just just have to
go away I mean I think that that was a
big motivator and and the two parts of
the Tea Party Movement didn't always
line up in motivation or aim but at
least the the Beltway circuit the the
intellectual Think Tank version of the
Tea Party Movement they wanted
entitlement reform and the Trump
movement and the conservative movement
in the year of Our Lord 2024 has no
appetite for entitlement reform they
don't want
it and the the people in the first group
they're going to say well it's just
because you guys don't understand basic
economics you can't do math you dummies
you just want something for nothing
you're becoming like the leftists but I
think the conservatives who have moved
on from entitlement reform for now
actually have an important point which
is that in 20110 we were told put the
social issues on Ice let's have a social
truce until we can deal with the true
Menace facing our society which is the
national debt we have to fix our fiscal
house and then we can deal with the
cultural issues and that didn't work we
elected the Tea Party Congress we
elected Republicans in the Senate we
didn't manage to ous Barack Obama we
elected a lot of Republicans around the
country and nothing
happened and and what we began to
realize
was you couldn't fix the economic
problems before you fix the cultural
problems actually all those Wall Street
Geniuses and all those think tankers in
many of whom were wearing bow ties and
Tweed they weren't they weren't right
about the fundamental premise of how
politics and human nature works you
can't just throw us all into a computer
and fix all the all the financial
problems and then deal with the cultural
problems were cultural even the Insight
of Andrew Breitbart that politics is
Downstream of culture in a way gets at
that point and the conservatives had
learned that lesson they had taken it to
heart by 2016 they said no we're going
to fix migration first we're going to
fix the family first we're going to fix
the sexual confusion first we're going
to fix the uh role of Washington DC in
our political life first we're going to
fix subsidiarity and federalism first
we're going to fix our communities first
and then and only then will we even be
able to think about these financial
problems
so what's it going to be for Nikki Haley
the her only role in the race is to be
the more
Centrist more
clubbable 2010 2012 style Republican
that's her only
role even if even if she wants to be the
newer kind of Republican that was the
danta strap if you try to be too much
like Trump in a race against Trump
you're going to lose CU you've got the
original no nobody wants New Coke they
want Coke Classic even if in a blind
taste test they prefer the taste of New
Coke so Nikki is going to have to have
to carry on that line the question is
now in a race where potentially Dan
santis gets out relatively soon in a
race where Chris Christie will be out in
a race where who knows what happens with
the
vague are there enough rep
Republicans who who who don't like the
uh new flavor of conservatism that that
came up in 2016 are there enough
Republicans who want to go go back to
that 2010 2012 consensus maybe maybe
politics is kind of slow and we often
run one or two cycles behind if the if
the new hip thing in 2012 is the Tea
Party who do we nominate we nominate
Mitt
Romney the guy who invented Obamacare
Okay so maybe I I actually think Nikki
Hy does in fact have a chance but she's
going to face more uncomfortable
questions like that speaking of changing
priorities good news out of the Vatican
yesterday Pope Francis condemned
surrogacy there have been some other
unfortunate things that have come out of
the Vatican an embarrassing book about
using all sorts of bizarre sexual
language from the the person who is now
the head of the dicastri for the
doctrine of the Faith once called The
Holy office one's called the Inquisition
you know the the doctrinal office of the
Catholic church and there's this kind of
odd book I won't even get into it
because a lot of it seems even kind of
obscene and so there was anyway there
was bad news coming out Catholics were
feeling a little bit low and then all of
a sudden we got this good news from Pope
Francis
and it's it's worth repeating because
the the people who think that Pope
Francis is just purely a liberal the
kind of liberal leftwing atheists who
applaud Pope Francis without without
reading everything that he has to say
they're going to try to paper over this
one but it's important he's not just
talking about IVF here which is totally
condemned and unacceptable according to
Catholic teaching he's not just talking
about certain kinds of surrogacy uh
homosexual couples renting out a womb
which is a phrase that Pope Francis uses
uterus for rent uh it's not not even
just that it's not just you know the
commercialization it's all of it Pope
Francis says I deem deplorable the
practice of so-called surrogate
motherhood which represents a grave
violation of the Dignity of the woman
and the child based on the exploitation
of situations of the mother's material
needs but Francis goes on to say child
is a gift end quote never the basis of a
commercial contract and he has called
for a global ban on surrogacy quote to
prohibit this practice
universally to prohibit what he calls
quote uterus for rent totally totally
right here three cheers for what the
Holy Father has said very very
important and the fact that Pope Francis
has some cache among liberals and
non-catholics and non-christians and big
lib
atheists I I hope we'll we'll allow this
message to resonate more because it's a
new bioethic iCal issue we don't have
2,000 years of experience of surrogate
motherhood it's it's just a a
development that came about because of
modern technology so a lot of people
don't know how to think about it
bioethic and in our modern culture even
many
conservatives have just accepted as if
by osmosis so many premises of
liberalism and the commercialization of
everything we don't think about it but
that's just the world we live in and as
a fish is unaware of the water in which
he swims so too we are unaware of so
much of the liberalism and the
commercialism and the materialism that
we walk around in but Francis Pope
Francis says it very well here he says a
child is never the basis of a commercial
contract it is a grave violation of the
Dignity of the human person to do this
even when there are the best of
intentions even when it's a couple
struggling with infertility I know I we
briefly went through it fortunately
there was a a very mild intervention
that worked and so it was no big deal
but for a couple years we went through
it so I know how profoundly painful that
can be what a strain that can put on
marriages and people will say well look
if if a couple's struggling with
infertility what's the big deal of using
a
surrogate the big deal is you are
treating a child as a as a commodity to
be purchased rather than a gift from God
the only person who can be said to have
any rights when it comes to procreation
is the child and the child has a right
to his natural mother and father join
together in holy matrimony and to be the
product of the conjugal Act of his
parents okay and and the the more we
Tinker around with this the uh worse
things are going to be because we will
be and we are not even aware of this but
we will be establishing the domination
of Technology over the very origin and
Destiny of human life a good example I
think of this is is a lawsuit that came
up just this year it was back in April I
think it was where a couple struggling
with in ility went to one of these quack
doctors and you know they managed to
collect the sperm in a way that is
Gravely immoral and they got an egg in a
way that's extremely invasive and all
extremely expensive by the way and then
whoopsy Daisy they mixed things up and
they created a child with the wrong
sperm and egg so this is not just even a
case of embryos being mixed up and you
know the black baby comes out of the
Chinese lady and you know white baby
comes out of the Mongolian I don't know
whatever I but
this was a case of a human being was
created whose parents had never met and
whose parents I believe in this case
were married to other people at least
one of them was I think both of them
were what do you do about that person
well it's a fringe case yeah it's a
fringe case because you've engaged in an
action that is intrinsically disordered
and Gravely immoral and so what do you
say well you know look well if this
happens one time out of a thousand
that's just life right no you've created
a human being because you've you've
reversed the order of responsibility of
of parent to child and you've treated
people like property to be purchased a a
person is never a property to be
purchased and owned you've disrespected
the rights of of a person and you've
done so for the best of intentions sure
the road to hell is paved with very good
intentions and this is a great
clarification so it's sad that it's even
necessary but it's a good clarification
from Pope
Francis as a father I am particular
about the kind of content that my kids
are exposed to that is why I'm thrilled
to present bent key our new kids
entertainment app from the daily wire
right now you can check out the world of
bent key for free for 14 days bent key
is the only kids streaming app that you
can trust to provide quality content
that aligns with your values and
worldview try bent key for free for 14
days that is 14 days of unlimited access
to Bent Key's world of Adventure use
code unlock a checkout and get 14 days
of free access to Bent key no strings
attached you can cancel any time once
you see the amazing content that bent
key has to offer you are going to be
hooked so do not wait go to Bent key.com
use code unlock at sign up to start your
trial today my favorite comment
yesterday from cheeky chimp who says
aliens in Miami I prefer the more
politically correct term Californians
that's a fair enough that's a good
point I assumed you would say you know
Hondurans or something like that but no
Cal actually you're right there's
probably a greater mass migration of
Californians into Florida than there are
of foreign Nationals very true speaking
of weird sex stuff it's that time of we
should just have a segment on this show
every day or every other day you know
it's a f minute segment weird sex stuff
there is a
scintillating story going around this is
this is what we've been waiting for the
Jeffrey Epstein files are going to be
unsealed we're going to find out all
this new juicy
information some of us told you at the
end of last year this was just a week
ago that we weren't going to get any
really new information
no Michael we are and next day they say
we are we're getting we're going to find
out about prince
Andrew oh the guy that we already know
about the guy that we've known about for
years he actually lost his job working
for his mom because we know so much
about his relationship with Epstein oh
okay we're gonna find out about Bill
Clinton do you know this is one of the
juicy tidbits Bill Clinton likes young
women stop the presses okay well now we
got new stuff Epstein documents allege
sex tapes of Bill Clinton Prince Andrew
and Richard
Branson this woman the accuser uh Sarah
Ransom claims that her friend was
approached by special agents sent
directly by Hillary Clinton who ruffled
her up after she went to police with her
accusations M Ransom later said she made
up the tape's existence okay now I don't
know maybe it's true maybe Hillary sent
some goons after this lady uh maybe not
I tend to think if Hillary sends Goons
after you you don't generally Live to
Tell the tale but maybe maybe and uh so
then she goes to the cops and she says I
I have all these tapes in my possession
now are there secret sex tapes of at
least some Epstein clients maybe
including Bill Clinton Prince anderw and
Richard Branson yeah I bet so I don't
know about those guys in particular but
certainly Jeffrey Epstein
videotaped his very wealthy influential
powerful
clients doing weird sex stuff with
underage girls
guaranteed the tapes
exist but is it these tapes does This
Woman This Epstein accuser who obviously
got kind of messed up as a young
gal uh does she have those tapes I kind
of doubt it I kind of doubt it because
in in 2019 this is what two two years
after she made these accusations this
woman told the New Yorker that the tapes
were made
up she said that she made this up to
raise Intrigue into Epstein's Affairs
and to convince Jeffrey Epstein that she
had evidence that would come out if he
harmed me so this is just according to
her in 2019 what do you believe do you
believe her in 2017 and then they
intimidated her and she recanted because
she didn't want them to kill her or do
you believe that the whole reason she
said that she had these tapes was to
create a kind of dead man switch and
give herself some apparent leverage uh
so that they wouldn't kill her and then
when she's talking to the police it is
difficult to lie to the police and the
story fell apart and she said okay I
didn't it that didn't really
happen I someone who believes that there
are sex tapes of all these weirdos on
Epstein Island I who have believed the
Jeffrey Epstein story long before many
mainstream voices believed in it I don't
think these these tapes are real I think
it's the latter I think she was a scared
confused woman who had a kind of
traumatic upbringing and she made it up
and then she admitted she made it
up I think that's true for a lot of this
testimony all of this testimony the
unsealed Epstein
documents it's all just testimony isn't
that convenient it's all just stuff that
could be false it's all some of which
has
the accusers have admitted was false now
to me it's just so convenient the only
people we're hearing about really are
the ones that we already knew about and
all of the stories that we're hearing
titilating scintilating that they may
be can easily be denied because they're
not findings of a court they're not the
conclusions of an
investigation they're just what some
lady
said Witnesses who may or may not be
credible I just think the whole thing is
a limited hangout I think it's all fake
and silly to get us all chattering oooo
it's I think we finally got to the
bottom of this Epstein thing no we
didn't no we didn't the bottom of the
Epstein thing is who was he working for
in whose service did he cultivate these
relationships operate the weird sex
mansions and islands and film the
tapes who if anyone was he
blackmailing and more importantly in
whose service was he doing the
blackmailing that's what this is
about and no none of the Epstein news of
the last two weeks has gotten us one
inch closer to finding out that
information very very
convenient okay one more at least weird
sex Stu story I don't know sometimes
these stories comes in come in droves uh
the World Health
Organization has picked someone among
others to set
guidelines for how they will approach
child sex
mutilations and uh one of the people
that they picked is a uh
lunatic alone but
[Music]
time with you it seems that when it
comes to the way our liberal political
order is structured the people who are
running the show are the very last
people who should be in those positions
of power not just that they are a little
qualified they're like the very last
they're the opposite of the people who
should have those jobs weird how that
works the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member use code NES KW at check out for
2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans